[Applause]
it's great to be back
great to be back not much has been going
on
I've been kind of a slow news period but
we've been off for almost two months
let me put things in priority for you
okay that's my job here okay the big
story a lot of things happen the big
story was the FBI we found out was
investigating the President of the
United States for being a Russian agent
if you remember one thing about the last
two months that's it and spoiler alert
he is he did nothing when they told him
that Russia was meddling in our
elections he fired Comey when he was
looking into that [ __ ] he wants to get
out of NATO he met Putin five times
that's a lot of times in just a couple
of years always with nobody around
nobody nobody can ever know what they're
doing forget collusion I want to know if
there's penetration
last week last week when this story
broke I saw Jeanine Pirro you know her
on fox news the the ultimate ass like a
Donald Trump and she's like asking him
the question like I have to ask this
ridiculous question she says mr.
president are you now or have you ever
worked for Russia and Trump said a lot
of words after that but none of them
were no he said that's the most
insulting thing anybody ever said about
me really more than when stormy said you
had a mushroom dick and then they send
rudy giuliani this guy out there to go
he said I never said Trump's campaign
didn't collude yes you did you said it
dozens of times it's on video just
because you're invisible to cameras
doesn't mean you don't show up in
mirrors
laughs thank you very much for carrying
me on that one
then today now today this big story came
out look we're a little disadvantage
here we're live live live it's Friday
night hi
we may look crazy in a couple of days
because they're still vetting this story
but BuzzFeed says that Trump wanted to
build his you know Tower in Moscow so he
told Michael Cohen his lawyer who
briefed the Trump crime family on this
like ten times when Trump was running
for president to lie to Congress about
this and Trump of course for me
the whole two years we've been I have no
deals we dropped nothing nothing going
on with Russia we stayed away nothing
pending no deals no nothing thieriot its
Putin I gotta take this
[Applause]
I love it when they ask Rudy Giuliani
about Michael :
what do you think about the lawyer
before you who was told to lock they all
like Trump and Rudy they lie so
blatantly before the next news cycle the
why has been disproved and then when
they're asked about Michael Cohen the
man's a liar but you can't trust a man
like that for you he's a liar that's
what his lies were for my favorite legal
defense of all time is you can't believe
my lawyer he's in prison
this is not just trumped by the way it's
Ivanka and Don Junior got regular
updates on this [ __ ] from Michael Cohen
yes this is the family that needs to be
separated and put in cages
[Applause]
but on the bright side you have a
three-day weekend coming up that's good
just what federal employees need another
day off well it is the 28th day of the
government shutdown and boy we are
really filling it here in LA I mean
between the furloughed government
workers and our LA teachers are on
strike and the usual army of out-of-work
actors and screenwriters at coffee bean
is crowded and by the way speaking of
that my sister is a teacher
our teachers are out strike here in LA
and I wanted to show my support so in
our audience tonight fighting for the
right things is the head of the LA
Teachers unit Alex Caputo pearl would
you take a bow
[Music]
I said he should stand you can't see him
but I hope you guys get back to work I
hope everybody gets back to work you
know air traffic controllers TSA agents
Coast Guard Border Patrol they're all
working without pay or what Trump calls
running a business and now you know this
whole pissing match has escalated in
some sort of East Coast West Coast rap
war between Trump and Pelosi which she's
kicking his ass by the way
he won't reopen the government till he
gets his wall so she said okay then you
don't get to come into my house and do
the State of the Union in the usual
televised way no TV until you do your
homework
first Trump was not having that nobody
puts man baby in the corner it was like
I'm not gonna let some woman push me
around his hand Coulter okay with that
so to retaliate to Nancy Pelosi you saw
this yesterday he cancelled a Nancy
Pelosi's military plane she was going to
go to Afghanistan to visit the troops
meanwhile as he's cancelling her
military plane Melania gets on a
military plane to go to Mara Largo now I
don't want to get into Trump sex life
but he also called on Melania to end the
shutdown
let's be the carnival of heart to the
drums it's their wedding anniversary
this week and Trump says he remembers
the first time he ever laid eyes on
Melania and clicked Add to Cart
you